[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING] [CLICKING]
SCOTT HUGHES: In the
previous lecture,
I began with the
Einstein field equations
in the most general form.
And then I specialized
to linearized gravity,
to taking the spacetime
metric, assuming
that I can find a coordinate
system in which it
is close to the
eta alpha beta form
that we use for flat space
time, plus a small perturbation,
something that's defined.
So I set whenever I have
that h multiplied by itself
I can neglect it.
Doing so I was able to
recast the Einstein field
equation as a simple linear
equation, which is the wave
operator acting on a variant
to that perturbation,
the trace reverse version
of that perturbation.
It is minus 16 pi g times
the stress energy tensor.
So in doing this
recasting, I have--
this is essentially just a trick
of reorganizing the variables.
I have taken my h
alpha beta, which
describes the way in which
spacetime is shifted away
from that of flat spacetime, the
perturbation of flat spacetime,
and I've just rearranged
that to give it
the trace with
the opposite sign.
And I've chosen a gauge
such that the divergence
of that trace reverse
metric perturbation is zero.
If we take this equation,
which is completely
general for
linearized spacetime,
the only thing which I had to
do is choose a particular gauge.
And there's no physics in that.
That's essentially
a coordinate choice.
If I then imagine that
my source is static,
I will have static fields.
And so my wave
operator goes over
to a simple Laplace operator.
And that it's not too hard to
show that the solution that
emerges from this looks
like this, where phi n is
Newtonian gravitational
potential, which
arises from a distribution
of mass like so.
So this is the leading solution.
And it's one that is very
powerful and very useful.
And it's actually
using tremendous number
of physics and
astronomical applications.
This restriction to a
static source, though, is--
well, it's restrictive.
What if I do not want to simply
consider a static source?
What if I am
interested in sources
of the gravitational interaction
that are themselves dynamical?
And so I emphasized last time
that this wave equation, my box
h bar alpha beta equals
minus 16 pi GT alpha beta,
this is something that
I hope you have already
seen in the context
of electrodynamics,
in particular whenever we have
a wave equation, who's not even
a wave equation, but any
differential equation
that is of the form linear
differential operator on field
is equal to a source.
OK, so I'm separating out time
and spatial behavior here.
Whenever I have a
situation in which I'm
interested in studying a field
in which some differential
linear operator acting on that
field is equal to a source,
we can solve this using the
technique of Green's functions.
I am not going to be able
to go through the technique
of Green's functions in detail.
I will quickly give you a
synopsis of how it works
and then I will look at the
particular Green's function
that applies to
the wave operator.
Students who would like
to read more about this,
I would point you to
the textbook by Arfken.
I believe it is called
Mathematical Methods
for Physicists.
And in the third edition,
Green's functions
are described in
Section 16.5 to 16.6.
So in a nutshell, let me just
give you a very brief synopsis
of how this technique works.
Suppose we take
our source, which
may be some complicated,
very ornate entity.
And what we're going to
do is replace that source
with a delta function.
So imagine that I
take s of t and x
over 2a delta at
some time t prime
and a three-dimensional delta
at some location x prime.
What I'm basically
saying here is
I'm imagining I might have some
source that's extended in time
and extended in
space, and I'm just
going to look at the little
blip at one particular event
and see if I replace my source
with this one single blip,
what field emerges from that?
What we're going to do is
assert that a solution exists.
And we will call the
field that arises
when my source is replaced
with a delta function,
we'll call it capital G. OK?
This notation means that this
is the amount of field at t, x,
arising from my source
at t prime x prime.
So my differential equation
for this solution G
now looks like so.
So whatever my linear operator
is when it acts on this G,
it gives me the source, which
is now the delta function.
Let me just introduce a
little bit of notation here.
So t and x, I call
this the field point.
This is the point at which
the field G is being measured.
t prime, x prime
is my source point.
This is the point at which
the source is non-zero.
In this particular
case, it's actually
a little delta function spike.
The reason why we do this is
pretty much by definition.
Pardon me one second.
Yes, pretty much by definition.
If I take the source
and integrate it
against the delta function--
integrate over all time,
integrate over all space--
I must get the source back.
This is a tautology.
All I'm doing here
is really saying
this is the properties
of delta functions.
However, what's sort
of remarkable is
if instead of
integrating the source
against the delta functions--
if instead of
integrating the source
against the delta functions--
I integrate the source
against the Green's function,
if I do this, then what
I must get out of it
is the solution f.
This is actually
very easy to prove.
Simply take this equation--
let's call this equation A--
if you take a equation
A and operate on it
with your differential
operator D,
so if I hit equation
A with D-- remember D,
it's a differential operator
that acts on only the unprimed
coordinates.
You know what?
Let's just go and
write this out.
So D on this integral,
when I hit D on this,
it goes straight
through the integral.
This only acts on the
unprimed coordinates.
So it ignores the integrals.
It ignores the s.
The only thing that operator
hits when I act on the integral
is the Green's function itself.
But I have asserted that
the Green's function is such
that when D acts on it, I
get the delta functions out.
And by the definition
of delta functions,
this just gives
me my source back.
So what this means is that if
we can find the Green's function
for our differential
operator, all we need to do
is integrate it
against our source.
And the result must be the
solution to our field equation.
It's a beautiful technique.
So if you haven't
seen this before,
I highly recommend that you
turn to that reading in Arfken.
I'm going to take
advantage of this.
I'm going to use
this technique now.
In particular, I'm going to
take advantage of the fact
that if my differential operator
is in fact the flat spacetime
wave operator, there is a
very well-known solution
for the Green's functions.
It's called the radiative
Green's function in this case.
I'm just going to write
down what the solution is.
So I'm going to talk about
the properties of this
in just a moment.
So I'll just comment
that this is something
that you should be able to find
developed in any good quality,
advanced electrodynamics
textbook.
In my notes here I suggest
looking at this place where
I originally went
through this carefully
was in the second
edition of Jackson.
It's presumably also present
in the latest edition.
But it might be in a
slightly different place.
In the second
edition, you can find
this discussed in Section 6.6.
When I have taught MIT's junior
level electrodynamics course,
I actually go through this.
And by essentially introducing
a Fourier transform,
a Fourier decomposition,
turning the wave operator
into an algebraic operator,
just rearrange a bunch of terms,
then invert a Fourier transform.
It's not too hard to show
that this is the result that
comes out of that.
Notice the argument of
that delta function.
And please bear in
mind, we are working
in units in which we have set
the speed of light equal to 1.
So the delta function,
it has support only at--
well, what's going
on here is this
is taking into account
the amount of time
it takes for information to
travel from the source point
to the field point.
OK, if I can illustrate
this with a little cartoon,
imagine I have some dynamical
source of mass and energy
that's down here wiggling away.
Here is my one example
of a source point
that is going to end
up inside the integral
when I integrate up the Green's
function against my source.
Here I am.
I'm an observer making
my measurement out here
at position x.
Whatever is happening
at x prime takes time
to be communicated to me
making my measurements out here
at distance x.
The time lag is the distance
that has to be traveled,
x minus x prime.
And, again, I'll
remind you, we're
working in units with a
speed of light is equal to 1.
We would divide by c if we were
working in normal SI units.
OK?
So this factor in the Green's
function is building in--
I'm going to do the
integral in just a moment--
it is building in
the fact that we
need to account for
the amount of time
it takes for information
about the source's dynamics
to be radiatively communicated
to observers far away
from that source.
All right, so we are
now going to apply this
to the linearized--
the Einstein field equation
for linearized gravity.
So here is our field equation.
Sadly, the letter capital
G is doing multiple duties
in this lecture.
So when we solve this,
what we need to do
is integrate t alpha beta
regarded as a function
of prime--
time t prime, position x prime
against the radiative Green's
function.
Plug in the radiative Green's
function, which we use.
This is the Green's function
that corresponds to that wave
operator.
We have a minus 1 over 4
pi hitting our minus 16
pi out front there.
We're going to do the integral
over the time variable.
And we're going to leave
our result expressed
as an integral over space.
This is an exact solution of
the linearized field equations
of general relativity.
This is telling me
that what happens--
the field that is measured, the
trace reverse perturbation that
is measured at
time t and position
x prime is given by
integrating over my source, all
the dynamics that happened
earlier than that time t.
What I need to do is take into
account that over this source I
have to fold in
the amount of time
it takes for
information from source
point x prime to go out to x.
I integrate over the source.
At every point in
the integrand, I
divide by the distance between
the field point and the source
point.
Do that integral,
multiply by 4G.
There's my solution.
This is wonderful.
It's actually an exact solution.
Like most exact
solutions, it's not always
the most useful
thing in the world.
There's one problem which
we need to diagnose,
which is that in the way that
this has been formulated,
it looks like every component of
this trace reverse metric looks
radiative.
What do I mean by
it looks radiative?
Well, it came from
a wave equation.
They all depend on
information that traveled out
at the speed of
light with a time lag
appropriate to the speed
with which radiation
moves in flat spacetime.
You know, you look at
that, and you sort of
say, wow, the entire metric
has this sort of character
that we associate with
a propagating wave.
All of spacetime is radiative.
We need to be careful
about that, because here
is where we need to
revisit and think
carefully about what happens
when we choose our gauge.
What I'm going to show you
is a little demonstration
that in this case,
the gauge we chose--
and let me emphasize that was
a wonderful gauge for putting
the horribly messy field
equation into a form where
we could actually solve it--
but the gauge we
chose is unfortunately
masking some of the physical
character of the spacetime.
So this Lorenz gauge
was great for producing
a set of field
equations that we could
bring to bear powerful
mathematical techniques
and get a closed
form actually exact
within the context of linearized
theory, an exact solution.
But it might be
misleading us as to what
the resulting solution means.
Let me illustrate this with an
example from electrodynamics.
Suppose I gave you a vector
potential that was of the form
at a time-like component that
was q over r minus q omega sine
q dot r minus omega
t capital R over r.
Little r is square
root of x squared
plus y squared plus z squared.
And capital R is some parameter
with the dimensions of length.
And my three spatial
components of this thing,
I'm going to write
them as kqi sine k
dot r minus omega t
capital R over r minus qxi.
OK, this is the potential that
has a form that kind of looks
like if I were to sort of give
this to you on an oral exam
and say without doing any
calculation, what would
you guess this is?
And that would
actually be, as you'll
see in a moment, that'd be
a very unfair question of me
to ask.
And I look at this and
I say, you know what?
That looks kind of
like a Coulomb field.
And then there is
something radiative
that it's embedded in,
kind of a funny amplitude
associated with that radiation.
But maybe this is sort
of like a dipole radiator
with a net monopole
moment going on it.
You know, we've got things
that involve fields that
oscillate in space and time.
They fall off as 1 over r's.
A component falls off
as 1 over r cubed.
Yeah, that would be my guess--
a point charged with radiation.
So your oral examiner,
the next thing they say
is, great, work out the
electromagnetic field tensor
corresponding to this.
So you do this by
taking some derivatives.
And what results is this.
This is the electromagnetic
field tensor corresponding
to a Coulomb electric field
with no magnetic field.
This potential is nothing
more than a Coulomb point
charge in a really dumb gauge.
The way I actually generated
this was I started with the q
over r potential of a
Coulomb point charge.
And I just applied some
crazy gauge generator to it
to see what happened.
So the parable of
this story is whenever
you are working
with quantities that
are subject to gauge
transformations,
you have to be careful about
drawing conclusions about what
those quantities mean in
terms of the physics you
want to get out of it.
Gauge can obscure the physics
if we are not careful.
And in particular-- there's
almost like a conservation
of pain principle here--
it is often the case
that the best gauge
for formulating tractable
equations for solving
your problem turn out to
be gauges that give you
just kind of crappy results if
you want to interpret what's
going on physically.
In the remainder
of this lecture,
I am going to introduce
something that's
a slightly advanced topic.
And I pretty shamelessly stole
this from a paper that I wrote,
something that I did
with a colleague of mine,
Eanna Flanagan.
And it's based on an
idea that was developed
in a different context by my
MIT colleague Ed Bertschinger.
So here is what
we're going to do
in the remainder
of this lecture.
What we're going to do is
recast the metric and the source
in a form, which
allows us to categorize
the radiative and non-radiative
degrees of freedom
of the spacetime.
This will, in fact-- we're
going to do this in a way
where the results are, in
fact, completely generic,
provided we stick to
linearized gravity,
gravity linearized
around flat spacetime,
which will be sufficient for
our discussion right now.
I will give you the
punch line upfront.
What we will discover
is that spacetime
has four physical degrees of
freedom that are non-radiative.
And the hallmark of
this is that they
are going to be governed by
differential equations that
look like the Poisson equation.
They will look like the Laplace
operator on some potential
is equal to a source.
Let me rewrite that.
This handwriting is terrible.
Spacetime has two more degrees
of freedom that are radiative.
These are governed
by wave equations.
The metric tensor of
spacetime has 10 components,
10 unique components.
It's represented by about
4 by 4 symmetric matrix.
OK?
So it has 10 components in it.
4 plus 2 does not equal 10.
You might look at
this and think,
what about the other four
components of this thing?
I've got 4 degrees of freedom.
That must correspond in some
sense to 4 of those components.
I've got another 2
degrees of freedom.
That must correspond to
two of those components.
What's going on the other four?
Well, the other 4
degrees of freedom
are essentially eaten
up by our gauge freedom.
OK, we are free to
specify our coordinates
via an infinitesimal
coordinate shift.
And so we have 4 degrees of
freedom under our control.
General relativity
insists on giving physics
to the other six.
These four non-radiative
degrees of freedom, the two
radiative ones, and the four
gauge degrees of freedom
completely describe
the spacetime metric.
And just to use an analogy,
these non-radiative
of degrees of
freedom are kind of
like the non-radiative
electric and magnetic fields
that you get in electrodynamics.
Your two radiative
degrees of freedom
are going to turn out to two
polarization states associated
with waves in the gravitational
field in the same way
that in electrodynamics, the
electric and magnetic field
also have two polarizations
associated with them.
So this is all worked out
in great detail in a paper
that Eanna Flanagan of
Cornell University and I
wrote about 16 years ago.
And so I will make available
through the 8.962 website
a copy of that paper.
And it was Flanagan who
sort of got this started.
And he and I then figured
out all the details together.
Ed Bertschinger is sort of
the grandfather of this idea
since he did
something very similar
in an analysis that
characterized perturbations
to cosmological spacetimes.
All right, so here's
how we proceed.
Let's consider h
mu nu as a tensor
field on a flat background.
In the previous lecture
that I recorded,
I described how when I am
working in linearized theory,
it's a useful fiction
to think of h mu nu.
Even though we know
it's actually telling us
about the curvature
of spacetime,
it's a useful fiction to
think of it as a tensor
field in a flat background.
And we're going to
take advantage of that.
We are going to choose
time and space coordinates.
Once I have chosen time
and space coordinates,
I then think about how
this 4 by 4 tensor, how
its different
components break up
and how they behave with respect
to rotations in the spatial
coordinates.
I can imagine going in and tweak
my spatial coordinate system.
And what I want to do is
examine how the components break
up into subgroups with
respect to spatial only
coordinate transformations.
What we'll see is h mu nu is
going to break up into-- you're
going to get one piece.
It's your time-time piece.
OK?
If I have chosen my time
and my space coordinates
and I imagine messing around
with my spatial coordinate
system, htt is unchanged.
And so this--
I'm actually going
to give it a name.
I'm going to call
it minus 2 phi--
this behaves as a scalar.
My spacetime piece--
so components of this,
of the form hti--
I'm going to characterize this
in more detail a little bit
later.
But these three
numbers are going
to behave with respect to
spatial only coordinate
transformations like a vector.
Likewise hij is going to
behave like a 3 by 3 tensor.
So let's break this down
a little bit further.
Whenever I am dealing
with a function that
is vector in nature--
and bear mind it's a field.
So I'm dealing with
a vector field--
I'm going to write this as
a divergence-free function
plus the gradient
of some scalar.
So what I'm going
to do is say hti
is equal to beta i plus
the gradient of some gamma.
And I'm going to require that
the divergence of that beta
be equal to 0.
Notice, since all of my
indices are spatial indices
and I am working in nearly
Lorenz coordinates--
the placement of the indices,
whether it's upstairs
or downstairs, is immaterial--
I will tend to write them all
in the downstairs position.
And so repeated indices--
we're going to sort
of abuse the Einstein
notation a little bit-- repeated
indices will be summed over.
Let's extend this logic to
the tensor piece, to hij.
This takes a little
bit of thought.
So let me just
write out the answer
and then describe the
character of every piece that
goes into this.
So hij can be
written as hij tt--
I will define that in a moment--
plus 1/3 hij plus d, sort
of a symmetrized gradient
of a vector epsilon, plus
delta i delta j minus 1/3 delta
ij plus operator on
some function lambda.
So let me go
through and describe
what each of these things mean.
And while I'm at
it, let me count up
the number of degrees of
freedom associated with them.
Let's back up for just a
second and do that over here.
Gamma is a scalar.
So there's 1 degree of
freedom associated with gamma.
Let me move this over to here.
So that's 1 degree of freedom.
Beta is a vector, but
it's divergenceless.
Because it's a vector,
I have three components.
But being divergence-free,
those three components
obey a constraint.
So that's 3 minus 1.
So this scalar and this
divergence-free vector
give me the 3
degrees of freedom I
need to specify the 3
independent components of hti.
Over here, as I look through all
of these different functions,
h is a scalar.
I have defined it
in such a way--
hold on just one second.
I'm going to come back to
that point in just a moment.
Epsilon j is a vector.
It is defined such that
its divergence is 0.
OK?
So what is going on here is
this contribution to hij,
it gives me a piece of
this thing that looks
like the gradient of vector.
This has 3 degrees of
freedom minus 1 constraint.
This is a scalar.
It only has 1 degree of
freedom associated with it.
Lambda is another scalar.
Notice whereas h feeds directly
into hij its derivatives
of lambda that feed into this.
So this has one
degree of freedom.
But this is defined
in such a way
that if I take the trace of
hij, this operator gives me 0.
Right?
So the trace-- what
the trace will do
is sum over elements
when i and j are equal.
So this will give me essentially
the Laplace operator.
But the trace of delta ij is 3.
So I get Laplace operator
minus Laplace operator,
I get the 0 operator
acting on lambda.
So this gives me 1
degree of freedom.
This gave me 1
hij tt-- and you
know what, I'm going
to go to a separate
board for this one.
This is a tensor.
tt stands for transverse
and traceless.
This is defined so that
if I take its trace--
oops, I said this would
all be downstairs--
if I evaluate this, I get 0.
OK?
So hij is a tensor
but with no trace.
And it's defined so that if I
take it's divergence, I get 0.
So this guy has 6
independent components.
This is 1 constraint.
This is 3 constraints, right?
Because it holds for
every value of j.
So this ends up giving
me 2 free functions.
So as we sum all these up--
let's see, did I
miss anyone here?
Right.
So I have totally
characterized h mu nu
by a set of scalar, vector,
and tensor functions.
I have a scalar phi,
which I have over here
with my time-time piece.
I have a scalar gamma.
I have a vector, beta i.
I have a scalar h, a scalar
lambda, a vector epsilon i,
and finally, a tensor hij tt.
OK?
So what I've done is--
let me just step
back for a second.
What I've been doing
in this exercise
is trying to figure
out with respect
to its behavior under
rotations and then
just because it'll prove to
be convenient in a moment
its behavior when I sort of
look at casting quantities
in this irreducible
form that involves
divergence-free vectors
and gradients of scalars.
This is sort of the
equivalent of doing
that for a tensor function.
The 10 independent
components in h mu nu
have now been encapsulated by--
I've got one function here 1
here, 2 here, 1 here, 1 here 2
here, 2 here.
1, 2, 4, 5, 6, 8 and 10.
So all I've done is rewrite
those 10 independent components
of h mu nu into a form,
that as we're going to see,
is particularly convenient for
allowing us to understand what
the gauge invariant degrees
of freedom in spacetime
are, at least in
linearized theory.
All right, so, so far,
all I've really done
is rewrite my metric using
a set of auxiliary variables
that might look a
little bit crazy.
What we would like
to do is examine
what my linearized
Einstein field
equation looks like in terms
of all of these new fields.
So in terms of the phi gamma
beta h lambda epsilon hij tt,
I would like to run this
through the mechanism,
make my Einstein field
equation, but express it
in terms of these things.
We'll see why that
is in just a moment.
But before I do this, we have
to be a little bit careful.
We have 10 functions here.
We have 4 gauge
degrees of freedom.
And the whole point
of this exercise
is to try to understand
how to deal with the fact
that a gauge that is convenient
for doing my calculation
may leave me with
a result that is
confusing in terms
of the physics
I'm trying to understand.
So what we're going
to do is say that I
can take my generator of a
gauge transformation, xi alpha.
I can write this since
I have chosen time
and space coordinates.
I can break it into a time-like
piece and a spatial piece.
I'm going to say that the
timeline piece is some scalar
field A. And spatial piece
looks like a vector field B
sub i plus the gradient
of some scalar c.
And I'm going to require
Di Bi to be equal to 0.
The reason why I'm doing this is
these functions that I came up
with, my phis and gammas and
betas and epsilons, whatever,
they are going to change
if I introduce a gauge
transformation.
So suppose I change
gauge as we learned how
to do in the previous lecture.
When you do this,
what you discover
is the function phi changes
to the original phi,
so something that looks like the
time derivative of that scalar
A. The beta picks up a term
that looks like the time
derivative of the
vector field B. Gamma
goes to gamma minus A
minus time derivative of c.
H goes to H minus 2
nabla square root of c.
So all of these functions
that we sort of cleverly
introduced trying to write these
different pieces of the metric
of spacetime in an irreducible
form, when we change gauge,
they change in this way.
I left one out.
It turns out when you change
gauge, hij tt goes to hij tt.
This piece is actually
gauge invariant.
That's really interesting,
because that tells me
that once I have
worked out my field
equations, the piece
of it that describes
this transverse
and traceless piece
of the metric
perturbation, it has
meaning in any representation
that I write down.
So the piece that
looks radiative in one
representation, in
fact, is radiative
in all representations.
We still have to
figure out what's
going on with all this stuff.
OK?
So we have a little
bit more work to do.
But we've just learned something
very interesting about this.
So at this point, there's
really no simple way
to describe what you do next.
Honest to god, what
you essentially do
is you just stare at
these things for a while.
And you start to notice that
there are certain combinations
of these different
functions that, like hij tt,
certain combinations of
them are gauge invariant.
So if I define capital Phi to
be little phi plus the time
derivative of my gamma minus
1/2 2 derivatives of lambda,
if I define theta as 1/2 h minus
Laplace operator on lambda.
I define the vector
field, psi i to be
beta i minus 1/2 epsilon i--
note, this vector field
is divergence-free--
and, of course, hij tt.
Every one of these combinations
is unchanged under a gauge
transformation.
But let's note something.
Phi is a scalar field.
Theta is a scalar field.
So I have 1 plus 1 functions
associated with them.
This is a
divergence-free vector.
So it has 3 minus 1 degrees
of freedom associated with it.
And hij, this is traceless
and divergence free.
And as I already
counted up, this guy
has 6 minus 1 minus 3 degrees
of freedom in it, also 2.
So when I characterize
the gauge invariant
degrees of freedom
in the spacetime,
I've only got 6 functions left.
But this is good, right?
My original 10 degrees of
freedom in the spacetime metric
are characterized by these
sort of 6 fundamental degrees
of freedom in the
gravitational field
plus 4 gauge degrees of
freedom that are bound up
in my gauge generators.
So what I would
like to do is see
if I can write
the Einstein field
equations in terms of
these gauge invariant
degrees of freedom.
And you know what, I'm going
to write it in its full form.
We're, of course, going
to linearize this.
But what I'm going to
do is take this thing,
write it in linearized gravity,
using my gauge invariant
variables.
Before I do this,
it's really helpful
to first decompose
the stress energy
tensor in a manner similar to
how we decomposed our metric.
So what I'm going to do is
I've chosen time and space
directions.
So I'm going to call
the time-time piece
rho in energy density.
The timespace piece, we
know that this tells me
something about
the flow of energy
or the density of momentum.
And I'm going to write this
as a divergence-free vector
plus a gradient of some scalar.
And I am going to describe
the space-space piece
as an isotropic pressure,
an anisotropic term--
I'm going to give you
a constraint on this
in just a moment--
some kind of a gradient
of a vector field,
and then a second order
trace free operator
acting on a scalar.
So, yeah, I'm going
to want to introduce
a couple of constraints here.
I'm going to require--
I've already written
out that the ISI is 0--
I'm also going to require
that the divergence of sigma
be equal to 0, the divergence
of the sigma ij be equal to 0.
And I'm going to require
that the trace of this
trace be equal to zero.
Let me strongly emphasize
that really all I'm doing
is rearranging terms.
I'm just trying to rewrite the
components of my stress energy
tensor using this
decomposition under rotations
and then looking
at fields that can
be written as divergence-free
vectors plus gradients
of scalars.
And I have a typo.
I'm just trying to do this
in a way that parallels
what I did for the metric.
OK?
Before I do this,
don't forget that I
am required to make sure that my
stress energy tensor satisfies
a law of local conservation
of energy and momentum.
When we do this, what we find
is that these various things
that I introduced here, some of
them are related to each other.
So in particular, what you find
is the Laplace operator on s
is equal to the time derivative
of the density, the energy
density.
Laplace operator
on the scalar sigma
is related to the pressure and
the time derivative of this s.
Finally, Laplace
operator on that sigma i
is related to also
the time derivative
of this derivative of si.
What this tells us is that--
so I really want to make sure
people don't get too hung up
on this.
This is really just sort
of the a convenient way
of reorganizing the
information in those terms.
But if you do want
to think about this,
this is telling us that only
rho, p, si, and sigma ij
are freely specifiable.
If you know these, there's a
total of 6 functions here--
1 scalar, 1 scalar, 3
vectors minus 1 constraint,
6 tensors minus 4
constraints, because this is
divergenceless and trace-free.
These are the only ones
that are freely specifiable.
They determine the
other 4 fields.
OK?
So density, pressure,
kind of an energy flow,
and anisotropic stresses.
OK, redemption is at hand.
Take all of the framework
that we developed
and that we discussed
in the previous lecture.
And let's grind
out the components
of the Einstein tensors.
Doing so to linear
order in h, which
is equivalent to saying linear
order in all of these fields
that we've introduced,
what you find
is Gtt minus Laplace operator
times this field theta.
Gti is minus 1/2 Laplace
operator on this vector field
psi minus the time derivative,
the gradient of the time
derivative of your theta.
And Gij, it's like
a wave operator
on the tt piece of your metric.
OK, that's a lot.
Let's equate them to the source.
And we'll take advantage of
the fact that when you do this,
you're always going to
associate like with like, OK?
Terms that are
divergence-free, you're
going to equate to a source
that is divergence-free,
things like that.
This completely characterizes
the Einstein field equations,
solutions to the
Einstein field equations
in linearized gravity.
Now, I want to make a couple
of remarks about this.
Part of what was the motivation
for this entire lecture
was this observation that when
we solve the field equations
using the radiative Green's
function, by construction,
the entire spacetime solution
had this radiative character
associated with it.
Everything sort of
fell off as 1 over r
and had a time dependence
that reflected a time
delay, the time it takes
for radiation to travel
from the source to the point
at which the field is being
measured.
But we saw via this
electrodynamic example
that we put up just
for intuition's sake,
that it's entirely
possible to have
a totally non-radiative field
that looks radiative basically
because we chose a gauge that
masked its physical character.
This was a lengthy and--
I'll be blunt-- a somewhat
advanced calculation.
I do not expect everyone
to be able to follow
this in great detail.
But I want you to understand how
we got to this final end result
here.
By decomposing the
spacetime, the perturbation
to spacetime in
linearized theory,
into sort of as irreducible as
possible a set of functions,
we found that there
are exactly 6 degrees
of freedom in that spacetime
that are completely
gauge invariant.
These functions, they
will have this form.
They will obey these equations.
In principle, you can
solve these things
and understand how these
fields behave no matter
what gauge you are working in.
And what we see is 2
degrees of freedom--
remember, hij tt
is a 3 by 3 tensor,
but its traceless and
its divergenceless.
So there's actually only 2
degrees of freedom here--
it is indeed a wave equation.
It is the only
piece of the metric
that is a wave
equation in every gauge
and in every representation.
All other gravitational degrees
of freedom obey something
more like a Poisson equation.
These are non-radiative.
This is radiative.
The way that we are going to
use this-- the next thing which
I want to talk about is
gravitational radiation.
And what this
calculation told you
is that if you are interested
in gravitational radiation,
this is the only piece of
the spacetime and the source
that you need to
be concerned about.
If you solve that
equation, it will give you
the gauge invariant
radiative degrees of freedom
in a spacetime no matter
what representation you use.
So we are going to-- for
the next couple of lectures,
we are going to focus on this.
We're going to show how we
can sort of solve the Einstein
field equations in a
particularly convenient gauge
and then say, all
right, I know I've now
got these 10 functions.
Four of them are
just purely things
I can get rid of by
choosing my gauge.
There's only six that are
sort of truly physical.
Of those six, four of them
don't constitute true radiative
degrees of freedom.
There's only 2 degrees
of freedom in my solution
that described radiation.
We're going to talk about
how to pull them out,
how to characterize them, and
the important physical content
that this gravitational
radiation carries.
So in a nutshell, you
should take this lecture
as demonstrating that in
a very deep way spacetime
always has some kind of a
radiative component associated
with it.
But it's really
only encapsulated
in 2 degrees of freedom
in the spacetime.
It may look otherwise.
But just be careful
that because your gauge
has confused you essentially.
And with that, I will
stop this lecture here.